so one of the questions we get asked
most often is what's the deal with us
and the guys from Freddy W do we live
together do we work together we work on
each other's videos what's going on by
this point it probably is not much of a
surprise that we pretty much use all the
same filming locations everyone sees the
similarities between all our videos and
that's because we both work and kind of
live essentially out of the same
building so as some of you guys might
know me Sam and Jake are from Stillwater
Minnesota it's a small town in the
Midwest and Brennan is actually from the
same place so time evolved eventually
they moved out it wasn't me Sam Freddie
Jimmy and Brandon all living the same
space
Brandon moved down the street Freddy
moved down the street but we all still
work in the same building so
professional relationship with Freddy
and Brandon basically consists of Freddy
building sweet minecraft houses for us
that's professional relationship with
Brandon consists of trading team effects
tips and talking about how great bullet
would be it has implemented in ray fire
it's not going to be all is going to be
it's coming right now we switched over
to thingy particles where we have bullet
suggests this is my dog Graham is first
last name comment she's doing so
actually I remember the first time I've
met you guys because Dora don't you were
coming over
Brandon once again my friends from back
home and I had no idea I was how could
we picture a very good impression
because if I go in and you are in the
back corner there and this was back when
the other people were living in there I
was cold so you also had fingerless
gloves on yeah you're sitting there like
typing and so here it is I was like I
kind of won't do music right okay we
need someone to do because
but we also we're really impressed ik
like I'm I was really into music games
also and like Freddy wasn't talking over
the survive in sounds like well I could
to me for anything
guitar your world I first met Nico ninth
grade in Minnesota we were we were in it
was confirmation group and there was a
confirmation retreat on a ski trip and
Nico and I we were basically first run
of the day we happened to get under the
same chairlift and I never met him
before we're sitting there we started
talking with amigo it was right after he
made his Star Wars fan film
Sam Sam yeah we got to talking about it
and I've got some tapas revenues like
let's do the halfpipe Europe meters that
have really done this alright we get
there and he goes like I'm gonna drop it
first and what he didn't know is that it
snowed like two feet the day before and
groumet rails yet because it through the
half bucket
it's like a little you drop some that a
pipe go straight it and there's like two
feet of snow there and his skis instead
of going up the halfpipe just go
straight in because I flop like flap
into the side of an F and we were
instant friends and later on our
relationship continued in high school
not as friends just reach friends you
know what actually blow stuff up my yard
me goes like that's really cool cuz I
love acting like I love actually was -
lets go blow stuff up after school today
we went on to compete it was my friend
Sam he's got a car
he's like Santa's good goats right over
to grass so all three was one of our
house then we blew step up and didn't
get in trouble ever never marry YouTube
there was a site called Alam DV calm
it's turned into FX home Alan Alan I
love you emissary Light and Magic was
that what it was yeah amateur stands for
G like Island Ohio in the state so it
was like a good native program that was
like after-effects light that was that
let you do like compositing and stuff
like that and I found it because I was
looking for Heather sweet like effects
for my movies in high school and they
sat on it - yeah I mean I would you be
like a community theater and it was like
things would have both like and most of
have like a thousand views or something
I remember I saw your guys's Metal Gear
Solid video that was one of the first
ones I saw and you guys are like hot
[ __ ] on that side we were because
there's always like oh my gosh this next
one there's like a matrix line because
only those of those on matrix fan films
lightsaber fights and then like Sandia
doing their thing it seems like three
hours downloading your 20 megabyte
biggest high-quality video file you
should pull at 25k Road I'm feeling a
seagull the farm aside which is all
right actually I'm a sign - inuyasha
good how'd you come up with these cool
titles I don't know I thought that when
I was like I was like whoa it's a drug
deal and they're killing each other so
it's like
pharmacist and other side 16 at the time
and on spring break us like there's a
lot of lights almost ran over those like
what is it Steve lavota and muscles your
own photos sweet yellow struck yeah like
it came like a point away from hitting
your feet it's going to like 40 miles an
hour Brandon and Carson I supposed to be
in the road and we
we're like Oh like in movies and the
cars like driving at people they just
zoom it in so what's the really calls in
the car
so we'll just deal with you guys the
ground freezes a little bit and so
they're gravel we're in a gravel road so
there's just kind of a loose rocks on
top of it so it's a little bit slippery
and I'll stand with my brother Karsan he
said there grow the driveways well this
white and his yellow truck Jack Jeff was
probably jacked about 12 extra in today
we told this come at us we'll get out of
the way don't worry and so Joe's in the
back with the gun when the trucks barely
dry when I was in a cosmic wait til it's
closer than you think
and so I'm like no it was like a last
possible second and I get so excited I
kick and I slipped with my foot because
a video clip you could see me like you
man just like you slip and then you're
you're panic mode kicks in imagine the
Wizard of Oz of that point look you
might've thought I just saw a tire leg
it is like yeah I wouldn't be walking
right again ever
probably that's like fully reconstruct
that's the dedication that these guys
bring to the video we can also be a very
good luck streak of learning things the
hard way but that's how hard suffering
the hard way just closer you see them
are very common isn't it okay don't yeah
i push it that far yeah exactly
so Internet that's that's what's going
on so nobody's questions are like wait
is this isn't this refrain of you shot a
bot said yes it is we're pretty good
shouting about
so get another free location well you
know what there's not
believe it or not phenomenon we do our
VFX enter there on the effects but we do
know hang out play video games to get it
yep a lot yeah you can all just do that
we're looking actually started
you